now you think how you act and how you
feel is called your personality and your
personality creates your personal
reality that I love that I love that so
if you're gonna change your life change
your personal reality you've got to
change your personality you got to start
changing your thoughts you gotta start
thinking about what you've been thinking
about and say do I really want to thank
this thing you become the Shepherd of
your thoughts the gardener of your mind
you start to become aware of your
unconscious habits and behaviors and say
my goodness how am i speaking how am i
acting
I believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves to create
the life that we really want and I want
to help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense
[Music]
today on the show is a guy named Joe
Dispenza he is an extremely
inspirational guy I have been reading
and listening and watching his stuff for
years and still quite frankly don't
understand half the words he says but he
is very inspirational he's a
best-selling author he's a researcher
and he is an inspirational speaker he
has spoken in over 33 countries holds
week-long advanced seminars to advance
your mind and create brain and heart
coherence he he's literally curing
cancer I mean this guy is amazing and
I've been learning a lot from him about
negative thoughts and how they can be
addictive I've learned about how we can
reprogram our mind learned about
meditation the best times to do
meditation the list goes on for the
things that he has inspired me to think
about and I hope he does the same for
you too because Joe is such a wealth of
knowledge the interview has been broken
up into two parts the first part is
about wellness and the body and the
second part is about consciousness today
we're talking about overall wellness of
the body and what you can control what
you can't control
and how your thoughts affect the pure
wellness of your body please enjoy
today's episode
I wanted you to start off by just sort
of quickly telling the story about what
really seemed as though it sets you on
this path of looking beyond what we're
told is how we operate as human beings
and that was when you got into a car
accident when you were 23 sure I mean it
was in a triathlon in Palm Springs I was
in the biking portion the race the cadet
was waving me on he had his back to the
traffic I made the turn and there was a
woman going 55 miles an hour on a Bronco
that just catapulted me out of my bike
and I won
braking six vertebrae in my spine now
when you compress the volume of material
like this when you compress that volume
bone fragments go back on the cord the
neural arch of one of the vertebrae had
broken and I had a lot of cord
compression so they want to do a radical
surgery for opinions from the leading
surgeons in Southern California said
Harrington run surgery or nothing and
screwing in stainless steel rods from
the base of my neck to the base of my
spine was the option to guarantee that I
would be able to walk again anyway I
decided against the surgery and in 1986
that wasn't a common thing that's why
because when I looked at first of all I
have a background I know a lot about the
spine so creating that kind of mobility
and if it wasn't done properly or if it
was done okay I could be in pain the
rest of my life I could be struggling
with the medications that could be
possibly addictive and that when you
start with the most radical form of
healthcare as a first choice you limit
the number of choices you haven't
started I was conservative and you work
your way up to the most radical you
always have more choices so I thought
well hell they tell me I'm never gonna
walk again what's the deal if I to it
now or I do it later right so I said no
to the surgeons in 1986 it just wasn't
something that you did and I just
thought there's an intelligence that
lives within us that gives us life I'm
not going anywhere I'm not doing
anything let me see if I could connect
with it and give it a plan where did
that part come from then
second part that you said is a lot
different than like oh the decision
between you know having potential pain
for the rest of my life and just like
taking my chances and starting slow and
seeing how this goes and like that's
different sure out of this yeah sort of
you know extensive intelligence that
exists that we don't really tap into
where did you ever get that thought well
I mean first of all that's a really
great point because you know the body
has an innate capacity to heat to heal
and if you study a very mechanistic view
about the way the body functions those
those are just models of understanding
but fast-forward to information biology
or contemporary understanding of biology
it's is more vitalistic that there's an
energy that the body feeds off of and so
then I was reasoning with the idea I've
been doing martial arts I at a yoga
studio I did I had gotten quite a
extensive training in hypnosis I was
interested in this stuff so I kind of
knew that there was an intelligence
living within us my background as a
chiropractor also believes in that
innate intelligence and so I thought
well that intelligence knows how to heal
but I want to see if I could take it to
the next level because it wasn't just
pain it was paralysis and sensory
changes and I went from very healthy guy
dealing face down yeah any we're
competing in a fitness competition
yeah like Here I am like you know that's
it so so so I just reasoned that if it
wasn't intelligence then I admittin I
could connect with it and so I decided
that I was just gonna give it a plan and
a template a design and then when I was
clear on that design I'd surrender it to
this intelligence because I can't do the
healing no said he all the way better
than me but I wanted to take it to that
next level bones heal but I want him to
heal better and it worked so did you do
that by pure intention well how did you
become the placebo Lee yeah so so I knew
that when you're when you're in pain
when you're in crisis when you're in
trauma yeah when people are out of
balance emotionally because of stress
the normal way the brain works is it
prepares for the worst so when we're
injured we're in crisis we're selecting
the worst thing that could happen to us
instead of the best thing that could
happen to us it could happen to us and
when you select that future there's an
emotional response like fear or anxiety
turns out that those chemicals give the
body and arousal rush give us a rush so
here I am trying to focus on what I do
want to have happen right but my brain
keeps going back to what I don't want to
have happen so six and a half weeks of a
dark night of the soul because yeah I
had to train my brain and I knew if I
said the design has to be pure it has to
be complete I have to reconstruct every
vertebra if I lose my focus yeah and I
start thinking about living in a
wheelchair whoops
that's the wrong signal so just by my
intuition I started working on my
presence my ability to pay attention and
stay present and every time I lost the
present moment I would come back and I
started to notice that when I got
frustrated and I did it would get worse
when I just noticed that it happened and
I came back non-judgmental yeah there
was just no emotional reaction there was
no charge and I was able to navigate and
at the end of six weeks I just felt like
I had a tennis Longstreet's so were you
just so was this meditation peer just in
meditation or was this intentional of a
visualization of something it was both I
knew that I'd have to first get in the
present moment yeah you know when
someone's present with you in your life
because they're paying attention you
know when they're not present with you
they're not paying attention so there's
an intelligence I got to be present with
it and create a very clear design so
then I would have to what I knew from my
background in hypnosis is I had I would
have to slow my brainwaves down
mm-hmm get beyond my analytical mind now
once I'm in that state I would have a
clear intention a very clear intention
and very clear focused and when I
started doing it well my emotional state
started to change instead of feeling
frustrated fearful impatient resentful I
was feeling joy and freedom and because
I was suppressing those emotional states
every time I got present because those
emotions bring us back to the path
so I had to work overtime and what I
didn't know that I was doing the whole
entire time was I was improving my
brain's ability to pay attention and
focus that means I could visualize
better yeah but secondly more
importantly I was able to relax more
into the present moment and by doing
that and holding a very clear picture I
started to notice very strong changes in
my brain I was laying down his circuits
I was creating a new mind and nerve
cells that fire together wire together
he keep doing it just like driving a
racecar it's gonna get easier because
you you you become what you practice but
you got to pay attention you got to
repeat it you got to learn you got to
keep experiencing so at the end of six
weeks it just kind of all came together
but those six weeks I was struggling
because it was just kind of this
unlearning process and prunings
neurological breaking habits of thought
and emotions and and then it worked and
so then I was back on my feet in ten
weeks and and then I just said if I was
ever able to walk again I'd spend the
rest of my life studying the mind-body
connection and mind over matter and
that's what I've been doing since 1986
hmm that's I mean I I think that you
know this is such a new wave of the
future this is I think there are so many
people that want new ways new improved
cleaner more homeopathic ways of taking
care of themselves people don't want
medicine people don't want to have to
fill their bodies with synthetics and I
think that this is really important what
do doctors think of this like do you
really like do you have that interaction
with practicing doctors and they say
listen I've been a teach me your ways or
do they say like they better get on
board in my opinion because this is to
me where things are gonna move too well
I mean first of all number one I think I
love medicine and I have a great respect
for it and it really works well for
chronic acute conditions yeah break your
leg yeah yeah but chronic health
conditions require a lifestyle change
that means you got to make different
choices and the hardest part about
change is making a new choice so go back
30 years and the doctor
said to you she said hey you need this
kind of health treatment for this health
condition we're gonna take out your
uterus and for in there we'll take out
your gall bladder
hmm everybody just said oh great thank
you you know yeah you think at all I
don't need it towards a day you got
information and information is awareness
and awareness is consciousness so
there's a change in consciousness about
what's available so when people get a
diagnosis today they don't just sign on
the dotted line
they actually research the real health
condition and you do that it gives you
more choices to make so then when they
start saying to the doctor hey I'd like
to try this treatment or I'd like to try
this therapy and doctor says well that
doesn't work or I don't anything about
that they say great time to find the new
doctor so people are starting to make
better health choices when they're in a
better position so during that time
there was not a lot of evidence
back in the 80s families that said that
there's possible in fact you were
considered a hippy right yeah but now
you fast forward to today and because
information is so available and people
are starting to apply that information
now we're starting to see dramatic
changes we've done numerous brain scans
to show that you can change your brain
in four days mmm for the better 80% of a
thousand people had a more than 90
percent change in their brain for the
better just by practicing meditation we
know that you can train your heart to
work more coherently that means that
when you're angry when you're frustrated
when you're impatient your heart beats
out of rhythm that's how powerful you
are
and it really suppresses certain genes
so then change your emotional state wow
you start to see people practicing this
kind of regulations we have evidence
that people can do that we have evidence
you can change your genes in four days
you can change your gene expression you
can make your immune system stronger by
changing your emotional state you can
lengthen your life with just 60 days of
meditation five days a week we've proven
that you can lengthen your telomeres so
now you have evidence that common people
can do the uncommon enough to be a monk
you don't have to be a nun you don't
have to be a priest and academic the
common people are beginning to wrap
their minds on this and do this evidence
this
just some mystical information so there
it is science is that model and then we
have testimony like we have people that
have healed themselves of stage 4 cancer
not once not twice not three times and
four times over and over again we have
people have healed themselves that were
blind that were deaf that had tumors
that had Graves disease hashimoto's
syndromes numerous Parkinson's patients
brain injuries MS rheumatoid arthritis
is where Jesus was doing back in the day
I mean Linus and stuff if anybody is
surprised oh yeah tell you that yeah
that's me I never thought I would see
these kind of changes now you have a you
have evidence right now in testimony so
no evidence becomes the loudest voice
right yeah so doctors now are saying hey
you're not really responding to
treatment I'm why don't you try this now
let me tell you why they're saying that
and that's because if you say try this
and you see the evidence of people
getting better and the person's not
responding to treatment what else do you
have and doctors are now referring
oncologists are referring patients right
to our office right to our of events
because it's an option for them so then
you have three types of stress physical
chemical and emotional stress is when
your brain and body are knocked out of
balance the stress response is what your
body innately does return it back to
order all organisms can tolerate
short-term stress but the chronic stress
is what pushes the genetic buttons that
create disease no most dress ends up as
emotional or psychological stress so
physical stress trauma accidents
injuries Falls chemical stress toxins
pesticides pollutants bacteria viruses
molds hangovers and then you have
emotional stress family tragedies second
mortgages single parenting 401ks
you know traffic whatever and all of
those things knock the brain body out of
homeostasis but the emotional stress is
the challenge because the person can be
taking care of their body you know
eating all the right foods taking all
the drugs taking all the right vitamins
all the enzymes doing the things doing
yoga during the long-distance running
whatever it is that they're into but if
they're living in constant fear because
of some threat in their outer world is
either real or imagined or they're
there's so mismanaging of their thoughts
that those thoughts keep producing the
fear so turning on that stress response
by thought alone then they could eat the
most organic healthy diet do all the
right exercise but the body's living in
survival because that's stress so now
you're mobilizing all this energy for
some threat in your outer world and
there's no energy in your inner world
for growth and repair and so you your
body is actually utilizing all of its
vital resources when it's feeling fear
when it's feeling aggression or anger
when it's feeling pain and suffering
yeah the body is mobilizing enormous
amounts of resources if you're being
chased by a tiger you're not gonna use
20% of your resources
you're gonna go all-in right so then
what if it's not a tiger what if it's
just traffic so what was once highlight
gets me becomes very maladaptive and
when you turn on the stress response and
you can't turn it off now you're headed
for disease so how does this I want to
talk about Tara DNA um and there's all
kinds of stuff and I'm learning about
this stuff as I listen to you and
various different different people like
you that talk about all these amazing
things but DNA like are we changing our
DNA are we capable of changing our DNA
well your body is a protein producing
machine muscle cells make muscle
proteins called actin and myosin so we
need to eat protein by the way that's
always something I wonder whether horses
really do okay
skin cells make skin proteins called
collagen elastin your immune system
makes amine proteins called
immunoglobulins or antibodies your
stomach cells make stomach proteins
called enzymes your eye cells make eye
proteins called keratin and then so the
body is a protein producing machine
every cell in your body
Danika makes a protein except for red
blood cells and and in order for a cell
to make a protein a gene has to be
signaled so this is a gene Gene's create
disease less than one percent of people
on the planet have born with genetic
conditions like type 1 diabetes
tay-sachs disease the other 95 to 99
percent people want to hear that and
people don't want to hear this not
because that means Lear can't be
available
you can't be a victim right exactly so
95 to 99 percent are created from
lifestyle you can take two identical
twins same exact gene expression same
exact genome one dies at fifty five the
other one dies at eighty one why they're
in a different environment or their
perception of the environment so now
it's not that the gene is a part slits a
list of possibilities right so now
here's the point
if a person is perceiving the
environment or or in an environment
where they're constantly living in fear
or anxiety or anger or aggression or
frustration then it makes sense then
that those emotions would influence
certain thoughts and certain thoughts
would make certain feelings or certain
emotions well if you're living by the
same emotions every single day you know
it's it's the environment that signals
the gene the end product of an
experience and the environment is an
emotion so your body is objective if
you're living in fear whether there's
any fearful conditions in your
environment your body's believing it's
an environment where it needs to feel
fear so then the person then keeps
signaling the same gene because they're
feeling the same emotion they're
responding to the same environmental
condition they're signaling the same
gene you keep making the same protein
you keep sailing the same gene over time
you just like taking a copy of a copy of
a copy of a copy all of a sudden the
body starts making a cheaper protein the
gene down regulates and now the body is
moving out of balance so then here's the
question if you're thinking the same
thoughts making the same choices
demonstrating the same behaviors
creating the same experiences that
produce the same emotions and then those
same emotions influence your very same
thoughts than your biology your
neurocircuitry to neuro chemistry your
hormones and your gene expression is
gonna be equal to how you think how you
act and how you feel and how you think
how you act and how you feel is called
your personality and your personality
creates your personal reality
I love that so if you're gonna change
your life change your personal reality
you've got to change your personality
you got to start changing your thoughts
together start thinking about what
you've been thinking about and say do I
really want to thank this you become
this
a pert of your thoughts the gardener of
your mind you start to become aware of
your unconscious habits and behaviors
and say my goodness how am i speaking
how am i acting we start looking at
emotions that you live by everyday and
say my goodness I didn't even know it
was guilt it just feels like me and or
lack and now the person's becoming
conscious of their unconscious part of
themselves and the more conscious we
become of the unconscious self the less
unconscious we go during the day so it
begs the question new thoughts that lead
to new choices new choices that lead to
new behaviors new behaviors create new
experiences new experiences produce new
emotions new emotions or the information
coming from the environment they signal
new genes and there's evolution so now
we up regulate the gene you start making
a healthy protein the immune system
starts up regulating and all sudden it
makes new antibodies why because the
body's back and growth and repair and
out of survival so we didn't we did a
research study for four and a half days
we took 35 randomly selected people and
we measured 7,500 different gene
regulations and what I want them to do
is to think differently make new choices
do different things have new experiences
and feel new emotions and we wanted to
see in the end of four and a half days
if they were able to change their gene
expression and they had eight genes in
common all of them shared the same gene
expression of these eight genes two
genes that suppress cancer growth and
tumors genes to grow new neurons in your
brain not just make new connections but
grow new neurons genes that stimulate
stem cells to go to damaged tissues that
are dying and breaking down and repair
them jeans for oxidative balance you
know anti-cancer anti aging anti the
heart disease anti stroke all had all
the same ones all these these are the
eight they had in common that there were
other ones you know that were great ones
as well but these eight were the common
ones and and and genes to strengthen the
cellular structure the microtubules of
the cell now genes are like Christmas
tree lights they're turning on and off
all the time but if you're doing the
same things feeling the same emotions
thinking the same thoughts you got the
same lights on on the other lights off
and over time you start signaling the
very
gene that's on the surface of your
genetic propensity and now you're headed
in that direction so then is it possible
then when you change your emotional
state will you change your gene
expression and the answer is absolutely
that you are your own genetic engineer
now it may take some time for certain
people's gene expression different than
changing your genes and actually yeah
yeah exactly and you actually reprogram
your DNA can you change it yes you can
alter you can alter your gene expression
now here's an example if your body's a
protein producing machine you have a
hundred thousand different proteins that
make up your body so you should have a
hundred thousand genes for every one of
those proteins okay you have forty
thousand was called regulatory proteins
that help make those so now you should
have forty more genes you should have a
hundred and forty thousand genes for one
hundred and forty thousand proteins and
when they mapped the human genome they
were so surprised that we only Express
twenty three thousand six hundred and
eighty-eight genes so how's that
possible because on one gene you can
have several variations several
variations of how the gene is expressing
itself so genes are always moving in
mobile hmm so we can is there a certain
timeline that you can established or
like reprogram like it can you do that
in a day can you is there how long like
if I said hey I want to change my
personal reality by changing my
personality which means I'm gonna
probably gonna change my thoughts and
that's inherently going to change my
genes because I'm creating new circuits
no patterns right well the answer is yes
and no we have people that have taken
for years as an example that we've
tracked that reversed a genetic disorder
that they had from a teenager
okay turn that whole battleship around
now that person was abused as a child
father was an alcoholic beat her every
day she felt weak punished of course she
developed a very specific bone disease
that created the weakening bone tissue
or scaffolding that's an expression
right so there were a lot of incidences
that branded her emotionally and she had
to get beyond those emotions not the
event just the emotions so someone like
that it took her maybe two and a half
three years to get through
now there's just like the form in a mile
hour never done whatever you say in
racing but there's a ceiling where
people said that was impossible mm-hmm
and all of a sudden human beings are
doing it so no yeah isn't there some
story about it with a four-minute mile
like once one person broke it then the
next year 20 did that's like literally I
was later someone there you go and then
there's 1,400 people that have broken
their doctors were saying it was
impossible explain how that works like
what what happened well it's in it's in
the field you have one thing happening
there's a footprint that somebody
stepped into unconsciousness that says
oh my god someone else did it I can do
it at the same time you're seeing the
evidence and three-dimensional reality
there's a footprint in consciousness
that the person can step into it's in
it's in the field now so at the same
things happening in our work what was
taking three years to happen 10 years
ago or eight years ago in one week we're
seeing people heal from the most
incredible health conditions and in
order for that to happen it's not some
miracle it is a change in gene
expression and that's exactly what got
me into measuring all this stuff in the
first place you see someone sitting in a
wheelchair for 10 years with MS at the
end of a weekend workshop she's walking
around the front of the room and hadn't
been out of that throne for 10 years you
start thinking that that's just not
nothing something happened there she
down regulated the gene for MS and she
up regulated the gene for health and she
was taking yoga in a weak and Egyptian
never done that before so I don't know
the timing because you don't know the
individual case mm-hmm by the same means
you could have someone doing the work
for six months they share to a weekend
event they're practicing they're ready
everything lines up and they have their
moment and their eczema goes away or
their health condition changes
dramatically you know that there was a
change in gene expression in that moment
so do you believe that we create the
disease in our body with disease do we
do believe that we create it are we
accountable I do I have to be very
careful about this yeah I am
a little practice probably like you
can't probably want to box yourself into
something but boom you see I just think
that it's really powerful if that's true
because then you're accountable and that
reality is so much different than well
but you know and then my dad had this
and then you know it's powerful nobody
held accountable then yeah so the answer
is yes and I want to say yes because
I've witnessed so many incredible things
in the last 15 years here I mean really
incredible things stroke patients that
were blind stroke patients that were
paralyzed you know moving their limbs
again getting out of wheelchairs I mean
so so I see that they can change it
because I think many people when they
realize that they contributed to their
health condition yeah then they
understand that that on some level they
created it yeah then they could uncreate
it is the cool part yeah that was a
practical simple choice that the person
makes right but then you know the reason
I hesitate is because there's exceptions
to every rule I mean I have my my best
friend's mother smoked cigarettes and
you know drank whiskey and was just one
of those mothers it was crazy and we
loved her but she lived like 90
something years old and you know well
you have other people that are you know
vegetarians you know running a 10k every
day do all the right things and you know
they make it yeah that's like you said
the difference between emotion right
course you know maybe you know your
favorite friends mom who was living it
up she didn't have any belief in the
world that she was gonna be sick from it
exam and then the person that's a
vegetarian and concerned about her
health all the time and afraid of
getting sick gots you got it you got it
you got it yeah absolutely that's the
truth and you once you know you can't
not know those people who don't you
can't unknown agreed so so people that
don't know yeah then don't understand
like that there's some how you say to a
person hey why are you so upset today
why are you so angry today why are you
so frustrated why are in a bad mood
today and they'll say oh I was at this
place with this person or these people
and these things happen to me and now
I'm feeling this way and I'm thinking
this way what they're really saying is
that person or that situation was
actually controlling the way they were
feeling and thinking so when things go
well in people's lives they say hey I'm
in a good mood when things aren't going
well in their life they say they're in a
bad mood so they're victims to the
environment right so now your thoughts
and feelings actually produce an effect
in your environment and when you begin
to realize that when you change how you
think and feel you change your state of
being when you change your energy you'll
see a change in your life now you got to
be able to sustain that you can't have a
great meditation and do something inward
and then get up in five minutes go
unconscious again you're taking that and
you have to bring it into your life and
be able to sustain it so then the person
who's responding consciously or
unconsciously to the conditions in their
life they don't know they're being a
victim to their life they're saying oh I
have this health condition or this is my
life until you start figuring it out
until you start knowing so knowledge
then becomes the forerunner to
experience so every time you learn
something new you make lots of
connections in your brain not a little a
lot an hour of concentration you'll
double double the number of connections
in your brain from from 1300 to 2,600
but if you don't I think up a lot of
hours of concentrated in my life yeah
pretty excited about that yeah and look
the same so let me finish that thought I
want to respond to that so then you're
laying down philosophical circuits in
your brain the more you think about it
the more you fire and why are those
circuits the repetition or thinking
about it yeah begins to install the
neurological hardware in your brain in
preparation for an experience so the
more you understand what you're doing
and why you're doing it then the how
gets easier so I now know after all the
research you give people the right
scientific information and science is
the contemporary language of mysticism
and they can turn to the person next to
them and explain it because that's what
you'll do I'll say now explain that if
you can't explain it it's not wired in
your brain it means there's something
now that's gonna be conjecture as'
something you're gonna just have a
little superstition about you know it
you're not gonna really understand what
you're doing and why
you can't explain something simply you
don't understand it well enough exactly
but when you can't explain it the model
of understanding you have the hardware
in place yeah it's going out today you
you set up the conditions and put people
in the experience if they get their
behaviors the match their intentions
they're gonna have an experience
experience then Rich's the circuitry but
the end product of the experience is the
payoff that's the emotion you start to
feel unlimited when you start to feel
abundant when you start to feel free
yeah now your body's getting the
chemical instruction to understand what
your mind was understanding
now you're embodying the knowledge do it
again there you go and then all the
sudden you start to master the
philosophy and overtime then you begin
to create a state of being that means
that you've memorized an internal state
it's it's subconscious the skill it's a
habit and you know that you know how to
do it you have to think about it any
longer right
so our job then is to start as
philosophers and initiates then masters
you know knowledge experience wisdom
mind body soul thinking - doing - being
learning with your head applying with
your hands knowing it by heart
and so when people follow those steps
they start we're starting to see this
four-minute mile thing go on and then if
I get somebody on the stage and I say
tell them your story on the lady says
well I'm from Holland I had stage 4
cancer the doctors told me I wouldn't
live more than three months I tried
these things and nothing worked and I
just went to the event in my Orca I'm
here in Cancun for my second event I
have no cancer in my body now there's
people in the audience with cancer and
they're looking at her and they're
saying well she doesn't look like a
movie star
you know it's not a Hollywood version of
a great is she had some bumps along the
way you know but it's evidence and when
you start seeing that kind of piercing
of that four-minute mile that level of
consciousness yes that footprint is
there in consciousness for people to
step into but by the same means there's
evidence in three-dimensional reality
it's no longer dinner conversation hey
did you see that lady with stage four
cancer from Holland she didn't look any
different than me she didn't look like a
vegetarian she didn't look like she
worked out every day she didn't look
like she just looked an average person
so nobody everybody starts relating with
that and you look
in the audience when that person's
telling the story and there isn't a
person looking away they're all leaning
in to watch this because again evidence
becomes the loudest voice I mean one of
the most fascinating things is is the
video of being at a hospital with
someone laying on the bed that has
cancer cancer it like tumors and you can
watch the tumors you know disappear yeah
that's just yeah and it explained how
that happens Wow
there were people standing around and
there's a whole it was a yeah yeah yeah
so I've seen that video so so the video
shows a tumor in the bladder and it's in
China and and there's a group of
physicians that come in and they chant
something like it's already gone or what
give thanks that it's already gone
they keep chanting the same thing they
keep creating the state emotional state
and you see that tumor shrink yeah right
a third either shrunk or disappeared
later but a trunk so here's the science
behind that and I'll give you an
understand there's like there was a
researcher from Yale University in the
1940s that was very very passionate
interested in studying the
electromagnetic fields around living
organisms now in the 1940s nobody was
doing that right it was just a different
guy so he started off studying eggs and
when he was studying eggs chickens you
know different types of bird eggs
salamander eggs lizard eggs reptiles
amphibians 100 percent of the time he
always saw the positive charge where the
head was and the negative charge with
the tail was now if you have positive
charge on one end and they lived charged
on the other end even magnet in that
magnetic field is actually in the shape
of the egg exactly okay so he starts
measuring you starts quantitatively
analyzing all these eggs and then he
goes right to women with the propensity
for uterine cancer and he starts
measuring their electromagnetic field
around their body as well as around the
organ and he starts noticing the same
exact patterns for uterine cancer and
every single woman that had a pattern in
the field that he measured had a pattern
in the physical body of cancer so but
there was a certain percentage though
that had some in the field but didn't
have the cancer in the body yet but they
ultimately developed the cancer so he
was looking at matter thinking there's a
glow of you know we're with us with his
measurements matters emitting a field
the frequency no he's it's actually the
field that's creating matter so change
the field and you change matter so think
about like the environment are you
saying no let me say it again
they the the woman with uterine cancer
had a certain pattern in the field right
yeah so then he starts seeing the women
with uterine cancer every one of those
women that had uterine cancer had a
pattern in the field that was the same
here's the field
you changed matter and we do this in our
workshops and we've seen tumors just
like that disappear what do you mean
change the field then ok so there's only
two components according to the research
that shows how to change the field
here's an example they did an experiment
where they took of people group of
people that were great healers and they
took these vials of DNA and set them out
in front of his people and they said now
listen this is a mindful function with
all of your intention we want you to see
this DNA wind or unwind in your mind
just keep seeing it whine to run one
winder on okay so I did it over and over
again over and over again they check the
DNA guess what happened nothing
intention did nothing to change the DNA
so then they said ok open your heart
create an elevated emotion and just feel
gratitude and radiate that feeling of
care and love into the field and let's
see if that changes as DNA they elevate
their emotional state they do it for a
period of time they check the DNA and
guess what happens nothing but when I
say to the people we want what I want
you to do is see the DNA unwind in
tension one frequency the electrical
charge in the quantum field and feel the
emotions you would feel as if it already
unwound elevated emotion magnetic field
and in the quantum over 20% of the DNA
and whelmed at a remote location so
thought being the electrical charge in
the quantum field feelings being
magnetic charge how you think and how
you feel
broadcasts a field so now not just any
type of field is gonna do that
it's got to be coherent so we practice
creating brain coherence we actually
measure it we practice creating heart
coherence why because once energy moves
right up in here and you can change
resentment or frustration or impatience
to joy to freedom to gratitude and we're
measuring to see if you're doing it I
can say the identity you're doing it I
could say not there yet gotta keep going
how do you measure it then just maybe we
have now it's called a HRV heart rate
variability monitor we put electrodes
and we actually similarly clip things to
people's ears so now when the heart
starts regulating it starts beating like
a drum and it starts to produce a
measurable magnetic field it's up to
three meters wide now that energy is a
frequency and that frequency can carry
information and that information is your
thought is your intent in other words
the elevated emotional gratitude can
carry the thought of your health the
emotion of suffering cannot carry the
thought of your healthy there's a
different set of thoughts so you can
think positively all you want and if
you're feeling miserable right your mind
and body are in opposition so we teach
people how to put these two coherent
signatures together the thoughts sending
the signal out the feeling drawing the
event back but the more coherent the
more organized the signal the more
connection you have to the field by
organize do you mean concise about what
you want or do you know it was being
good at it no like rhythmic okay so so
coherence is a synchronization as an
example when people are under the gun of
the fight-or-flight nervous system
they're living by the hormones of stress
the arousal of those chemicals drives
the brain into a faster brain frequency
called high beta brainwaves okay in high
beta the arousal ooh you're in survival
what you're trying to do now is control
and predict everything in your life
right and so you start thinking about
your boss your coworker your boyfriend
you start thinking about grocery store
think about we have
oh all the things you have the finances
and every one of those things elements
people places has a neurological network
in your brain so as you shift your
attention very quickly you're activating
those circuits and like a lightning
storm in the clouds your brain starts
firing very incoherent lis and when your
brain is incoherent hmm you're
incoherent at the same time you're
stepping on the gas your heart's racing
because of survival a stepping on the
brake like I can't I can't throttle my
coworker even though I want to so you
can't fight and so now the heart starts
beating incoherently so how do you
reverse that so we teach people how to
create more order in their brain and
there's a formula that we practice and
when they do it right the brain starts
getting very organized those different
compartments that were subdivided start
to synchronize the rhythm even to the
firing oh there's a like I'm like we
have unbelievable measurements of rhythm
so I think about it so now all of a
sudden those different communities of
neurons that were out of sync start
synchronizing and what sinks in the
brain links in the brain and all of a
start then all of a sudden you start
seeing more and more neurons start
dancing to the same rhythm they start
synchronize I can ffunny and when when
that starts to happen when they start
getting more organized if you think
about coherence like a group of people
clapping in an audience say there's a
thousand people and you say normal
coherence for an average human being
would be every fifth person in the
audience clapping at the same time right
super coherence what we're measuring
imagine a hundred billion neurons all
synchronized you know a thousand people
all clapping at the same time not only
is the creating more order but any more
energy now waves start stacking on top
of each other and all sudden you start
getting more energy in the brain more
synchronization and all the areas that
were no longer in balance start to come
together and the side effect of that is
now the person starts feeling more whole
is there I'm thinking of two different
things one is a little more spiritually
based where there's in certain
ceremonies whether they be like
ayahuasca ceremonies that are getting
more popular or just maybe old maybe
Native American cultures and how there's
African cultures how there's rhythm
there's drums to their ceremonies
there's spiritual ceremonies there in
drums get everybody's thinking the same
way moving the same way feeling the same
way and community yeah so yeah so is
there a sister can you get yourself into
this state with a forced sort of
absolutely absolutely absolutely in fact
we use certain music when we induce that
that kind of coherent state that there's
there's a rhythm to it there's a
mathematical quality about it that
entrains the brain where you stop
thinking it just starts it starts
slowing brainwaves down so we use music
and and rhythm as also something I've
done back my very first IndyCar race I
get in a huge accident and afterwards I
was like on all the modalities you could
possibly be on but one of them was a
headset and goggles with light and sound
and so is that also what something like
that is doing is uh
sinking your brain Opry train is that
what would that be doing so the
frequency of the light a lot of times
and the sound starts causing the visual
cortex and the auditory cortex to begin
to oscillate and starting training so in
trauma well that's a good thing to do
because actually the opposite happens so
you're trying to save the person from
moving out of disorder in your brain
because that the fear and the anxiety
and trauma really shocks the brain mmm
interesting you were talking about
energy you're talking about the heart
and things of that nature and it makes
me think of you know the seven chakras
and the energy centers and what is your
understanding with that with that and
how they play a role in mm-hmm so so I
use the word energy centers because if
you say chakras some people will have
the wrong understanding of them all
right I agree I don't get fantastic that
you try and make sure that this is
digestible and attractive and not
off-putting to anyone right there's no
point in using religion or spirituality
right it's just science and as far as
you know this goes it's not
chakras and
no ceremonies and drumming its rhythm
its frequency and of course yeah
as we're sorry my here energy centers
yes so am I gonna doesn't want to call
yeah yeah but it's cool because these
different energy centers of the body are
centers of information they have their
own frequency they have their own energy
they have their own little individual
brains or not they have their own
hormones their own chemicals Wow
you can measure that they have different
hormones oh absolutely each other you
say everyone and there are seven there's
seven okay well there's eight but seven
ones in the body so those different
circuit boards are under the control of
the autonomic nervous system
now stress creates imbalance in the
autonomic nervous system the sympathetic
nervous system is switched on for one
reason emergency for preservation hmm so
then you were mobilizing enormous energy
to preserve the body and it should be a
short-term thing the other nervous
system the parasympathetic is for growth
and repair right so some people spend
the majority of their time living in
that high frequency of stress so then
teaching people then how to make a move
from that sympathetic system into the
parasympathetic system means they have
to practice on a daily basis certain
fundamental principles and and for me I
think that well more and more people are
doing it how do you do it so when a
person begins to slow their brainwaves
down they have to go when you're in
stress when you're in survival you
narrow your focus on a cause that's
called a what's called a convergent
focus so now you're blessing the energy
centers of the body that run the control
of the autonomic nervous system and when
the autonomic nervous system moves out
of balance the brain moves out of
balance right we now our focus on the
cause and it causes each one of these
different energy centers to move into
incoherence as well and those little
little individual brains start moving
into in coherence and send an incoherent
message to the cells and tissues and/or
hormones then become downregulated and
the body starts moving out of balance so
when we bless the energy centers where
we reprogram these energy centers two
things has to happen they have to be
able to slow their brainwaves down they
have to get out of that high beta state
and the way we do it is to go from a
narrow focus to a broad focus when you
open your focus when you open your
awareness that's what creates coherence
in the brain because you're going
against that habit of putting your
attention on matter so there's a
convergent focus which is focusing on
matter and then there's a divergent
focus which is focusing on energy
well reality is both particle and wave
matter and energy so if a person can
slow their brainwaves down from beta
brainwaves to alpha brainwaves now
they're starting to fall out of their
thinking brain right into the home of
the autonomic nervous system the person
can't change their brain waves it'll
never work because they're in their
neocortex and there's thinking mind
right so that's one thing that has to
happen the second thing that has to
happen is that they have to practice
both a convergent focus and a divergent
focus now the convergent you're focusing
on let's say I'm gonna focus on this
energy center right and then you move
your focus to another energy so first
you first you focus on that energy
center that's particle and then you
focus on the space around it that's wave
and so when you open your awareness and
you're able to do that and you're in
your autonomic nervous system you can
put an intention there which will create
more balance and estrogen more balance
and your sexual organs you move to your
second Center you put your attention
there that's your where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so now you're beginning to direct energy
yeah into that center but now you become
aware of the space around why to create
coherence and that little brain send the
coherent message the cells and tissues
go to your third Center right in the pit
of your gut well there's a huge celiac
plexus there or solar plexus a lot of
connections in there so now put your big
one that's a big always getting a lot of
signs they're here in here those are big
ones and you tune in to that energy then
you put your attention in your heart it
has its own individual brain yeah and
when you make energy here when energy
finally arrives here guess where it goes
automatically straight up we've met
so now once you start opening your heart
you got more ninj in your heart you get
more energy in your brain got it time
just go straight to the heart that's why
we do it that's exactly why we that's
why we open the heart so it creates a
field and it begins to drive energy of
the brain so now that energy is gonna
cause the person to have a different
consciousness a different thought
pattern right and now they're gonna be
thinking possibility because in survival
the first three ones are all about
survival yeah it's really not a creative
process of creating from mind it's more
about a more primitive you know
humanistic part of us you know animal
part of us so then there's the thyroid
plexus the pineal gland the pituitary
gland so we've seen when people create
coherence in each one of these energy
centers than they do it properly they
know how to change their brain waves
they go to the operating system they can
master convergent and divergent focus
they're no longer living just this way
they've practiced opening their
awareness and focus on energy becoming
conscious of it and as these brains
become more coherent and they start
producing different signals to hormones
and chemicals and into different glands
in the body that's what's being
upregulated to make different different
expressions we see things like
colorectal cancer change prostatic
enlargement prostatic cancer impotence
diverticulitis you are uterine tumors
acid reflux and food allergies high
liver enzymes heart palpitations
arrhythmias much anything
yeah well each one that's related a lot
of hashimoto syndrome thyroid oh those
are so they're related to an energy
senator each one of these are an Energy
Center this one they they hold the
information for let's say that
reticulate us or they hold the energy or
why is this why is the cells and tissues
and organs functioning out of balance so
you can't control that with your
conscious mind you got to get beyond
your conscious mind and stay conscious
in your subconscious mind and that's
what we do when we slow our brainwaves
down but we don't want just any kind of
brainwaves we want coherent brainwaves
so then the coherent message the selsun
one of the things that I do when I
meditate which I don't do nearly enough
but I try and do as much as possible as
I I breathe into each of those energy
centers
and just feel for resistance feel for
tension if there is then I breathe some
more it's not probably nearly a thorough
enough process but I I can intuitively
feel where there is some resistance and
then I breathe into it also
interestingly enough I don't know what
you know about crystal balls and alchemy
and sound healing and if that's
something you've ever explored but I
went and did a session where I chose the
bowls and I had no idea until I was done
that the bowls they have their own notes
and when I listened to the bowls to pick
them because it was like a two-hour
intuitive process and I would close my
eyes and she would play the bowl and I
could literally tell you I was like whoa
my heart's like on fire like it it
related since it is a note musical note
it related to an energy center and they
that is exactly how it works I'm like
wow
I can feel exactly where it's hitting
right in and vacinated and and your
awareness contributes to that because as
you become aware of those energies
saying yes what you're actually doing is
you're in training that Center to a
harmonic of that frequency and these are
called hormones per face in because
begin to harmonize them and we do that
we practice we have I think eight now
different energy center meditations that
we do that's an evolution of the last
one and we teach people how to program
them how to create more harmony in them
yeah yeah and and and and we see a lot
of changes in their in their health yeah
can you explain epigenetics yeah I mean
we kind of touched on epigenetics
meaning above the above genetics meaning
gene and so it's not the gene it's the
signal outside of the cell right
so again epigenetics means that there's
some environmental signal that's
actually conditioning the circuit or
selecting and instructing different
genes so but here's the thing and people
will say well yeah it's the environment
but I lived in a great environment but
again if they're living by certain ammo
keep them connected to the past the
environment we're talking about is not
the environment out there it's the
environment around the cell the persons
living in the same emotional state or
the same let's just say toxic state
because if you're not chemical - if you
keep living keep exposing the cell to
the same state of chemistry mm-hmm that
cell of course then is going to weaken
so the emotion is that thing so you know
- factory workers working side by side
in the same plant both exposed to
asbestos a carcinogenic chemical one
gets cancer and the other doesn't
now why is that because it's the
internal environment right around the
cell it's different than the other
person there so meditation is such a
huge part and obviously we've talked
about that quite a few different times
how frequent do you need to be
meditating and how long are you about
making a difference yeah make a
difference in your life
you know there's so many variables um
again it depends on how how sick a
person is how incoherent their brain is
what type of trauma that they're healing
from emotionally there's a lot of
variables their lifestyle is their
ability to pay attention and focus to
understand information there's a lot of
different variables but let's just say
that it was someone like you or me that
wanted to produce some type of change in
their brain and body there's two times
the door to the subconscious mind opens
up when you wake up in the morning let
me go to bed at night your brain waves
just fluctuate you go from beta to alpha
the theta to Delta when you go to sleep
at night when you wake up you go Delta
Theta alpha beta so when you wake up a
little early you're kind of in low level
alpha or a theta you're between worlds
perfect time to meditate because you
have to work as hard to change your
brain which you're already kind of there
and so if a person can actually know the
formula of how to change their
brainwaves you can do a very healthy
good meditation for 40
five minutes to an hour the problem with
most people is they find so many
instrumental benefits from doing it that
they're not waking up like oh I kind of
meditate they're waking up like I can't
wait to do it
so it's instrumental for a lot of people
so most people in our community spend
about forty to sixty minutes that do it
some people spend a little bit longer if
they're working on activating latent
system sort of mystical experience or
whatever but I'm not a big fan of a five
minute meditation I'm not a big fan of a
10 minute meditation unless it's just
for a moment to stop and get grounded I
think you can go to deeper and deeper
levels and when you start making a path
you know carving a path yeah down into
that subconscious yeah the important
point is like when you're going down
that path and all of a sudden there you
go you make the right and you're with
your ex and you go home the best thing
is back up and go down again that's a
victory that's a victory right there you
became conscious then also you start
thinking about what you have to do at
two o'clock in the afternoon
all right you back up you start heading
down again that's a victory most people
don't have the patience to do that
because it's tedious in the beginning no
plasticity yeah working on it you keep
doing it you carve that path right down
the subconscious the nerve trunk is
gonna get bigger it's gonna produce a
bigger Road because there's more traffic
going on it now the person is able to
get there a lot faster and they could
have a great meditation in a half an
hour because they know how to change
their brainwaves right no I have I've
been doing this a long time and I have
sat with myself for hours sometimes you
just have to work really hard because
you got people you got meetings you got
to travel you got contracts you got all
these things you've got family and you
sit down the meditate in your brain is
just going to the future of the past and
oh yeah and you have to takes a while to
set get a centered and if it's like an
hour to get there I don't care if it
takes me I will not get up I'm not that
type of person until I'm there I just
will not and yeah every time I go past
that point where I want to stop you know
that point where I've had enough and you
just go no longer no longer you step
right into the unknown you're really
good at pushing the only way to the
other side
through and there's no growth with
unless there's pain I say that all the
time with discomfort discomfort yeah
because change is leaving the known and
leaving the know much the discomfort
sooner and they have to you have to and
listen you have two choices when you get
into that discomfort and I've learned
this just in the last few months in
witnessing some some really cool things
we're doing right now if you if you move
into the discomfort and you run back to
the known but you're not conscious that
you're doing it you just throw in a
program just do what you know how to do
because it's uncomfortable yeah now
you're just returned back to familiar
territory and that's a program people do
it so they they run some habit and run
some program the other choice is in that
is in that discomfort to apply the
formula and apply it with your eyes open
because that's where we're going because
we have students that can do it with our
eyes open as well as their eyes closed
now what's the significance of that no
person no thing no experience in your
life is gonna take your joy away you
could have a thousand reasons that day
to be unhappy right and you're gonna
self-regulate because you know how to do
with your eyes open it exactly right
that's where when someone we're going
there because we want people to stay
calm Wow in that's the moment that
matters the most so now we've done so
many great studies to see that our
community can really really create brain
and heart coherence right they can do it
in a meditation it's quiet it's in the
room it's beautiful as music playing
there's thousand people know let's take
them out in a situation put them in a
situation yeah where now they would feel
fear of some comfort and it's real it's
no longer hey you create your reality
and then there's nothing that's not a
moment you want to hear I thought you
had discomfort was sitting around in a
room for a nude up let's step it up so
we put them in situations now where they
normally feel fear or some strong
emotion that where they want to throw in
a program like I got a rush through this
mmm-hmm and we say hey hey why don't you
apply the formula right now so then the
person has to what their legs shaking
and everything going on they start
settling their body down they start
mastering their fear and so when they
return by are they meditating in public
and though their eyes are open well
they're just like zooming out practicing
and heart coherence with their eyes open
that's the next stage because when they
return back to the
and they face off with some ranching
situation they'll apply what they did
right they won't fall from grace and not
throw on a program and they'll open
their heart and go against thousands of
years of fear that's been programmed
into a human being - saving your life -
yeah for that reason and all of a sudden
the person now has a new tool then they
get back to their life and they've just
done something really outstanding and
they look at the challenge in their life
and they see it as minimal compared to
what they just did so their perception
of the way they see the world change
yeah and so now the person then starts
liberating enormous amounts of energy
you know there goes all the fear and
they have really profound moments so so
we want to we want to always press the
envelope I'm just that type of yeah
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today I hope you
enjoyed it and also thank you so much
Trevor Hall for the awesome music if you
like what you heard today and you want
to hear more please click on the
subscribe button
[Music]